wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus den usa jetzt ein bluttest
entwickelt mit dem sich ein großteil der
tumorerkrankung in einem sehr frühen
stadium erkennen lassen dass ist genau
das an dem forschungsteams weltweit seit
jahren tüfteln ihr habt euch dieses
thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt
jetzt alle wichtigen facts zu diesem
bluttest der wirklich weltweit für
aufsehen sorgt was kann er wirklich und
bedeutet dass jetzt das wär kriegs
endgültig den kampf wirklich an sagen
können jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
schon lange sind forschungsteams auf der
suche nach methoden die es möglich
machen die diagnose von krebs alleine
auf der grundlage einer blutprobe zu
stellen und das möglichst früh damit der
kampf auch gegen die typischen
krebsarten nicht schon gleich mit der
diagnose verloren ist seit 2016 gibt es
in der schweiz ein bluttest mit dem man
darmkrebs diagnostizieren kann die usa
haben nachgezogen 2017 den ersten
blutbasierten screening test zum
nachweis von darmkrebs auf den markt
gelassen
das alles erscheint aber wirklich klein
gegen das aktuelle forschungsergebnisse
dass in der wirklich renommierten
fachzeitschrift science präsentiert wird
ein forschungsteam der columbia
university stellt darin eine neue
methode zur früherkennung von krebs vor
und jetzt haltet euch fest demnach sei
es möglich gleich acht und damit sind
wirklich ein großteil der krebsarten
dabei in einem frühen erkrankungs
starken nachzuweisen tumore in brust
lunge bauchspeicheldrüse magen leber
eierstöcken darm und speiseröhre
das klingt alles wirklich erst einmal
war doch wie genau soll das
funktionieren und ist diese publikation
tatsächlich seriös
das forschungsteam nutzt für die
sogenannte flüssig biopsie liquid
biopsie zum verständnis wenn größere
tumore entstehen zerfallen auf
krebszellen die dann ins blut
ausgeschwemmt werden
dazu gehören auch proteine die als tumor
marker schon heutzutage genutzt werden
um den krankheitsverlauf zu
kontrollieren aber auch dna bruchstücke
werden frei die dann im blut zirkulieren
der neue bluttest mit dem namen cancers
sieg also krebs suche kombiniert die
suche nach acht charakteristischen
proteinen mit der suche nach der dna von
16 krebsarten die beteiligten
forscherinnen und forscher glauben dass
der test später nur etwa 500 us-dollar
kosten wird das
weniger geld als eine darmspiegelung in
den usa käufer dafür notwendig einzig
und allein eine einzige blutprobe der
test wurde bislang an rund 1000
patientinnen und patienten durchgeführt
die meisten dem start um zwei oder drei
und tatsächlich die sensitivität der
gesamtgruppe lag bei den acht krebsarten
im gesamten bei 70 prozent
das heißt durch die anwendung des tests
wurde bei 70 prozent der patienten
patienten die erkrankungen tatsächlich
korrekt erkannt
weiter zeigte sich dass der test
zuverlässige ergebnisse liefert je
weiter die krebserkrankung
fortgeschritten war besonders hoch weil
die trefferquote bei r stock und
lungenkrebs 98 prozent der erkrankungen
wurden auf grundlage des blutes zu
identifizieren anders dagegen sah es bei
den brustkrebs patientinnen aus hier
wurden anhand der blutproben nur ein
drittel der erkrankten erkannt dazu
kommt in einer kontrollgruppe wurden
sieben von 800 personen als krebskrank
identifiziert fälschlicherweise denn sie
waren absolut gesund andere expertinnen
und experten weltweit sehen die studie
deswegen auch durchaus kritisch ein
großes manko sei eben die hohe gefahr
für falsche positive testergebnis im
klartext es ist nicht ausgeschlossen
dass gesunde menschen die diagnose krebs
bekommen
das führe zu unnötigen und kostspieligen
untersuchungen und zu einer großen
verunsicherung in der bevölkerung aber
auch ärzte und ärztinnen könnten
verunsichert werden und der etablierte
vorsorge methoden wie etwa mammographien
oder darmspiegelungen weniger nutzen
das würde im schlimmsten fall bedeuten
dass eine krebserkrankung unerkannt
bleibt und für den patienten oder den
patienten tödlich endet von der ag
molekularpathologie der deutschen
gesellschaft für pathologie dgp heißt es
in einem offiziellen statement um die
methode anzuerkennen sei es notwendig
zitat eine einzelne an krebs erkrankten
personen ohne symptome aus mehreren
hundert gesunden personen und personen
mit anderen erkrankungen korrekt erkannt
werden und das ist bisher nicht der fall
trotzdem ist es natürlich wahnsinnig
spannend und ein absolut sensationell
ansatz wenn er als erstes neues zum
thema krebsbehandlung zu allen anderen
themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allem vom
neuesten video täglich garantiert um am
anfang gibt es noch ein kleines goodie
und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
glocke vergessen wie geht s weiter dafür
draufklicken mit krebs mit smartphone
diagnostizieren noch ein anderer
revolutionäre ansatz ansonsten bis dann
eben auch so geht's bleibt dran